every universe is different each one
just a fraction you need
thus the infinity stones are unique
of course the crusher was designed to
destroy the stones on my world not his
oh oh now it matters okay all good i
feel a bit better
what let's get out of the logic the
logic in this show it's it's like a
russian doll with a russian doll with a
russian doll
endlessly fun to open
true facts true welcome back to new rock
stars marvel studios what if we wrote
the rules of the mcu the game is
changing but empires are the same
but after the infinity stone supposed
retirement adventures end game are these
stones like most retirees of our world
just say an f you to all laws because
nothing really matters anymore for them
this is inside marvel it's our weekly
deep dive into all things marvel and now
that what if season one is complete we
are gonna do our best to answer the
biggest what the ifs you may still have
after this season finale i'm eric boss
crossing those what and dotting those
gifts with me is empty
are you doing empty i'm feeling good i'm
missing what if a little bit it's weird
not having anyone this week i am too but
it's been nice to have a week to digest
it to unpack it to
rank it in our heads with all the other
marvel disney plush shows we're gonna
get to our rankings at the end of this
episode how this really lines up
in this
marvel disney plus experiment of 2021
that's changed our lives for the better
i think hell yeah but a week after the
what-if finale the biggest question that
people are bound to continue tweeting at
us for the end of time is really
how the hell the infinity stones work on
this show yeah because episode by
episode we were given really new rules
for how each stone or really all the
stones have functioned across these
different universes now it'd be fine if
marvel wanted to move on from the
infinity stones as their sacred
macguffins as seemed to be the case
after in game and after loki but by
bringing them back into the universe
with what if and by insisting that all
of what if is 100 canon it really forces
the viewers to try to mentally justify
how these narrative absolutes that
characters were restrained by that some
characters died over are essentially
totally different things with different
properties now
really for the deaths of iron man thanos
black widow to matter or for how one of
maximos powers work or for what exactly
hulk did to trigger the celestials in
the upcoming eternals we really need a
straight answer on these rocks and now
we're finally gonna figure this out
together
i feel it
we're gonna do it for the people for the
nerd people i feel ready to do this
to embark on this sacred quest with you
do it but before we do
let's head over to newrockstarsmerch.com
to grab some symbiotic chaos shirts it's
a really cool shirt designed inspired by
venom let there be carnage so you can
grab one in blue or black so you have
options depending on whatever your mood
is that day there's also uh some really
great shirts inspired by shanghi suicide
squad and of course what if so if you
buy one of these latest obsession shirts
you will get the option to leave a
custom shout out that will run during
inside marvel episodes like brian asks
what if uatu swore an oath to kang
that's an interesting thought
actually we're gonna address uh uwatu's
connections with the tva and with kang
well we'll talk about that chris asks a
similar question what if the watcher
will have to reckon with the tva in
season two i hope so i hope they find a
way to connect and i have some ideas for
how we might get there and then
timeless124 asks what if mcu hulk was as
strong as comic hulk
hmm that would be a crazy overpowered
hulk because comic hulk is no joke yeah
he can thunder clap planets in the dust
want to see it yeah i would love to see
him throw their cup of planet to dust
but maybe not mcu earth that there's too
many nice people there no i mean yeah
yeah of course but all right mt what's
our big question for this episode of
inside marvel well it's gotta be
what if the infinity stones function
under different logic or are they just
plot holes because it kind of feels like
puddles
it does sometimes right especially after
episode nine i had really resigned to
the infinity stone logic on the series
just never really sticking to any
consistent rules but upon further
reflection mt i've realized that no no
this has to work you just gotta think
your way out of the depths
just gotta do that leap of faith out of
the uh out of that weird hole that bruce
wayne was in
gotta
untether ourselves from the rope and
just go for it exactly right dark knight
rises metaphors land we can make it
but we gotta recap okay so an end game
we were told that the infinity stones
were atomized in the present mcu with
their duplicates taken back to their
origin points in the sacred timeline and
the filmmakers chose to keep that return
journey off screen which i believe was
really the origin of much of this
post-end game confusion around the
stones
which i get why they didn't show it but
the fact that we just didn't see it
everyone's like whoa what what happened
could this happen
i need to see things to believe things
right and then in loki they made this
bold choice of having the tva keeping
duplicate infinity stones from pruned
branch timelines as junk paperweights
casey's junk paperweights which makes
them extra special and uh it's kind of
like andy writing its name on a wooden
spot
crazy doing that he's like these are my
stones i know other people these are my
stones these are my stones and then your
angry stones just in case
now while these stones are powerless
within the boundaries of the tva it's
never stated that these stones would
still work back in their home timelines
if they were ever reinserted or if
multiple functioning stones could
coexist in a single universe but it is
implied that the original six stones in
the sacred timeline still lived out
their histories and the stones from end
game and prior were still just as
important as they were before uh but
then mt tell us what happened and what
if in what if episode one in a separate
universe red skull uses the space stone
a stone that was supposed to allow
manipulation of space like you know
telekinesis phase shifting and opening
teleportation portals like the bifrost
to open a gateway to another dimension
that contains tentacle monsters which is
a scary dimension don't want to go there
and then you know sends captain carter
forward in time through this portal
yeah sure why not
i mean how could we justify this well
you could argue that some dimensions may
be accessible through quantum meddling
that the space stone has power over
similar to how the quantum realm is
accessible through extreme shrinking in
just those dimensions time is irrelevant
like in the dark dimension quantum realm
you know there's time vortexes et cetera
that could justify how peggy carter's
allowed to jump forward 68 years or
whatever but then in episode four dr
strange uses the time stone mostly
similarly to the way it works in the
films like the creation of time loops
etc however he instantly jumps back to
the night of christine palmer's death
that was several years prior when the
time stone is really supposed to
function with a more tedious rewinding
of time yeah you're gonna have to just
like fast forward through it like it was
the 90s it's a blockbuster they told you
to be kind and rewind
that's right
we started struggling that is kind of
weird how like with what if we're just
like all right we're just gonna put you
there she's like we don't have time we
don't have time we only have 30 minutes
30 30 to 33 minute episodes no longer
than that
but also this episode establishes
christine palmer's death as something
called an absolute point which the time
stone cannot undo or bypass unless you
absorb enough mystic beings to give
yourself power over an infinity stone a
new rule
that's right new rule now this doesn't
mean that the concept of absolute points
cannot also exist in the live action
titles and in fact the what a producer
said that had they written these
episodes after loki came out they
probably would have called these
absolute points nexus points or really
we should say unnexable points because
you know they cannot be branched from
um so really this episode i think made
the right moves by establishing more
limitations on the infinity stones that
did not exist before like we knew the
infinity stones were powerless in the
tva coming out of loki and now we know
the time stone is blocked by these
absolute points but we know that those
rules are irrelevant to supremely
powerful beings yet so far no logic has
really been broken in the mcu it's still
mostly worked you're just kind of adding
new rules to it and that's fine i think
we were okay with that and you know
episode five ends with zombie thanos
possessing five out of six infinity
stones awaiting the mind stone in
wakanda and in order for this to make
sense thanos would have had to take the
time stone from the zombie remains of
doctor strange in new york but then
rather than go to camp lehigh to get the
mind stone from vision somehow know that
the mind stone would be headed to
wakanda yeah so this is an example of
the writers not really focusing on the
logic of which characters could know
what when really this is the most common
plot hole that exists in almost every
movie and tv show when you think too
hard about it and that's why i think
this is forgivable you really could just
stretch and reason that maybe thanos
didn't know where the mind stone was but
he reasoned that it would likely end up
in wakanda as the world's safest place
and then it just got overran but then
episode 7 ends with the introduction of
ultron infinity which is where i think
the infinity stone logic gets a bit
muddled on the show because ultron can
only transcend into this universe
because he has the six stones which is
really another new rule possessing all
six stones gives you access to the
multiverse
which you know would have been helpful
for thanos to know during the infinity
war movies but he's just like i
i don't want to test it i'm just going
to stay within this universe and then
turn half of people into dryer lint hey
he had a specific goal and he just
wanted to stick to it that's right i
mean i guess you could argue that the
2014 version of thanos and endgame was
ready to just kind of rip at all the
pieces and start over but he didn't
think like i'm just going to go universe
by universe to make sure that it happens
i just don't like this universe well i
just think that that probably boils down
to like ultron's body being more
adorable than thanos's at the end of the
day uh durable and more efficient you
know i think as a robot he doesn't he's
not clouded by any of these uh uh
humanistic notions of awareness or
owning a farm
[Laughter]
farmers got their own priorities right
and you cannot tell a farmer to think
imperialistic um but really it's a big
deal the moment ultron stepped into that
desert degree party thor because his
stones could now co-exist in the single
universe alongside the stones of party
thor's universe so if the six stones
could now transcend universes it
contradicts the suggestion that they
were more limited back from episode four
bound by their home universe trumped by
the tva and it contradicts our
understanding from the comics like when
reed richards found the stones to be
powerless when he crossed over into the
multiverse marvel comics established
that to prevent the stakes of one
universe from undercutting the stakes of
another universe and that allowed the
stones to matter to one set of
characters in one universe absolutely
while keeping some sense of law and
order to a multiverse with duplicate
characters crossing over with each other
like you don't want a multiverse where
if any bonehead gathers the right six
stones he can render all of it pointless
that just kind of ruins the fun of it
and that's also quite terrifying i i
don't want to live i could not sleep
well in that universe like any any joe
schmoe jeff bezos can just collect all
these stones and make everyone's life
miserable are you kidding me make
everyone an amazon employee i don't mind
a terrifying multiverse i just want one
that has some kind of sense of
consequence
okay okay i feel you there consequences
always good consequences consequences
but yes episode 8 further confuses the
logic with the way ultron steals the
stone from thanos because after the
events of age of ultron thanos arrives
with the infinity gauntlet missing only
the mind stone and that would mean that
he took the time stone from the ancient
one of this universe and the soul stone
from vormir but he didn't sacrifice
gamora because she was shown to be alive
on the sovereign planet yeah right at
first we questioned how this thanos also
could have gotten the power stone if
xandar was shown to be undamaged in that
episode but uh i did later find an
animation detail showing how the nova
prime headquarters seemed to be under a
bit of reconstruction but that the
animators included that detail to
suggest some continuity makes it even
stranger why they would choose to
include gamora when it was you know her
sacrifice by thanos and infinity war
seemed to be the only way he could have
gotten the soul stone like he didn't
love anyone else he didn't
he didn't love nebula that much right if
he could abuse her it seemed like there
was a special relationship that made
that so important
i mean i do have a feeling that him and
ebony ma may have kissed at once yes
there's something
going on
it was all about my
humble personage get off your knees
people are looking at me
not now
[Laughter]
now looking back on that episode 8
moment i think really the writers try to
skirt past fan confusion about the logic
of all this by making this just a quick
joke and a shock gag like zap just split
in half right uh that ultron could be so
lethal with the mind stone that he could
just get the drop on thanos like that
and i gotta admit as we were watching it
for most viewers i think the gag worked
we just kind of shrugged it off the
first time we watched it and really i
think if this were the only time the
show bended the logic around the stones
i don't think anyone would have cared
but you know combined with all of this i
think for a lot of viewers it really
exemplified a trend on the series of
producers insisting that all this
mattered that all is 100 canon and then
routinely making a joke out of the
continuity that has until now really
been the mcu's most impressive asset
like think about it when jimmy wu showed
up in one division doing that same magic
trick that he learned from scott lang
man the wasp ooh baby baby that was the
gold that rewarded the fans and lines us
up to support this whole franchise even
through its weaker moments but now for
sure this is what if so you can take
liberties absolutely please take
liberties just show us that you're
sticking to some inner logic that you
have done your homework the way loki did
like so much of loki was just kind of
like telling viewers we know what we're
doing there is a plan here we are
sticking to rules like even the finale
episode was just a conversation talking
about the rules and we loved it it was
gripping this is true and i think the
the what if finale tried to do that with
the failure of gamora's infinity crusher
because gamora's device comes from her
universe where she and tony stark killed
thanos on cigar somehow kind of wish we
saw it but i guess that's season two um
but the device doesn't permanently
destroy the stones from ultron's
universe because the device isn't from
that universe and it's later said that
the watcher intended for this to happen
as part of his huge complex big brain
plan to misdirect ultron and contain the
stones in a pocket dimension for all
eternity so the show is suggesting that
there is some law in order between
universes and the stones and that the
stones can cross over into different
universes but they can only be destroyed
by things from their native universes
yeah right right right and i agree with
you mt but i honestly think that makes
things even more unruly and lawless it's
kind of like pandora's box
right yeah it's kind of like saying if
there's a wildfire you can only
extinguish that wildfire with rainwater
from the cloud that that initial
lightning bolt that started the fire
came from or by using uh the tears of
the guests from the gender reveal party
that ignited the place
right
it's like just use any water
why do we have to use that
because that is it that is it in
california it's just like some dopes in
bakersfield who need to fire a cannon a
pink or blue smoke and a bunch of dry
brush
good lord just slice a cake it's a blue
cake or a pink cake or just decide it's
a baby it doesn't need to have a gender
it's so true it doesn't need a gender at
all man like why are we doing this stop
lighting california on fire jesus christ
but really at the end of the day it's
what you're this rule is not a limit
it's a limit on the safeguards against
those forces of chaos
and then the finale episode really just
reverted back to stone confusion by
showing doctor strange use his time
stone against ultron's time stone and
they kind of just like cancel each other
out but it shows that limitless
duplicate stones can be used infinitely
with any universe with zero consequence
and one way that you can look at this is
that none of it matters chaos reigns
supreme everything's broken and that is
the point that everything you wear is
broken exactly it's all broken intently
so that we can explore the ramifications
of this broken multiverse in titles like
spider-man no way home doctor strange's
multiverse of madness sure i get that
but i reject that interpretation because
whatever happens in no way home or
multiverse of madness there is no way
either of those titles could top the
threat of a perfectly evil robot god who
cannot be killed and wants to kill
everyone in every universe ever like
no way home multiverse madness there
probably could be really cool dope
stories but they're not going to go that
crazy with it like they're going to keep
it specific to these characters and you
can make a story that matters more to
the characters right and of course
seeing it in live action is going to
raise the stakes by default like seeing
actual tom holland or or elizabeth olsen
or bennett cumberbatch have to go
through these things and their faces
react to this madness it's gonna be
super exciting but just the logic of the
story
what if immediately jumped the
multiverse shark by having ultron go
this ham and as a title that uh would
need to set up multiverse of mattis i
just think it went way too hard already
so that's why i don't think we're gonna
have to look directly at what happened
and say that's why things were broken
and furthermore i don't think what if
intended to end on such a nihilistic
note like clearly it has its own
intentions for some semblance of order
as the season drew to a close so empty i
think the best way to walk away from
what if season one is to assume that
these events were actually governed by
some rules even if the series didn't use
its airtime to discuss them explicitly
at length though a way loki and avengers
end game did so let's nail down four
rules that i think are actually still in
effect all right the four commandments
give me give it to me moses
[Laughter]
rule one hey stop worshiping that cow
god watch me not cold enough
all right rule number one in what if
each of these separate universes were
actually created by nexus variances that
really ripple affected the timeline in
all kinds of unexpected ways on and off
screen so that the infinity stones are
not always in the locations that they
were in in the films so this helps
justify theodos's acquisition order in
the zombie episode and the ultron
episode in the zombies universe order
just fell apart on earth resulting in
this happy accident of zombie thanos
being in the right place at the right
time to get the mind stone and in
episode 8 when ultron got vision's body
that nexus variance prevented thor from
locating the stones and led to ultron
using the mind stone to lay a trap for
thanos potentially clearing a path for
him to get all those other stones kind
of like olmec unlocking all the doors of
the hidden temple after you grab the
relic it's just just go the path is
clear for you and then come into my arms
and then i'll slice you in half
exactly sir you could call [ __ ] on
that rule but i do think it is a rule
that the writers held themselves too
basically chaotic causes but specific
results that jig saw the finale together
in this narrowly tailored way do you
accept the rule do you accept the rule
empty let me think about it
rule accepted
that's right
uh rule two infinity stones in the mcu
are depowered in specific buffer zones
that include the tva the void the
citadel and can be limited by specific
clauses within the sacred timeline some
of which may still be unenumerated so
this means that kang and the tva are
protected from the infinity stones and
that absolute points may actually be
kang's way of trying to limit the time
stone's effectiveness within the sacred
timeline but the very introduction of
absolute points in episode four tells us
that there could still be all sorts of
unenumerated rules to the infinity
stones that the mcu may still introduce
in the future when it benefits their
stories to do so
which could be frustrating or exciting
depending on how you look at life but
i'm going to use a latin phrase here
ignorantia juris non excusat
wow ignorance of the law excuses no one
when guardian leviosa eric
right exactly you may not know what the
speed limit is on this road but you
still have to assume that you just have
to pay attention to the world around you
is basically what that means you can't
just wander into a foreign country and
kill someone saying i didn't know it was
against the law
wait murder is illegally here that's
weird
it's fine
when you go traveling around the world
you have to know what the laws of that
country are and you can you have to live
within those laws and there may be laws
that spread it's like the seinfeld
finale i didn't know there's a good
samaritan law in this weird new england
town but it doesn't excuse you for
breaking it so just because we have not
seen a piece of world building in the
mcu yet doesn't mean that those elements
haven't existed out of the boundary of
our perception since the beginning we we
just could have yet to see it so that's
very true it's basically for
constitutional scholars this is the
unenumerated powers clause of the mcu
they can do whatever they want just
because it isn't spelled out in the laws
so far it doesn't mean that they can't
do it if only
all of our jurists held themselves to
that
right
anywho uh rule three infinity stones can
co-exist temporarily in a single
universe but cannot be weaponized to
destroy the stones native to that
resident universe right so this was the
rule given to us by the ancient one in
end game and it remains true after what
if what it technically didn't change
anything there because the ancient one
established that the stones are
necessary to maintain the proper flow of
time kang you could argue needs them to
fuel that sacred timeline gamora's
infinity crusher merely atomizes stones
preventing their use the way thanos did
in the garden at the beginning of end
game but in endgame despite those stones
lingering energy their lingering
presence in that present universe the
avengers were able to bring in some
duplicate stones from the past variant
branches to restore the dusted now they
didn't reverse thanos snap five years
had still passed there's still that
consequence and that's because the
original six atomized stones were still
dictating the flow of time in that
universe they just permitted these guest
stones to do a bit of redecorating in it
okay right that makes sense so in what
if episode nine when doctor strange uses
the time stone to neutralize ultra's
time stone he's successful at canceling
out the magic and the way that it's
being used on his fellow guardians but
he cannot use his stone to destroy any
native stone to ultron there and the mcu
has established this because stone
existence is more important than the
absence of stones to their stories but
their one limit on that is our final
rule rule number four infinity stones
cannot be destroyed they can only be
contained
and the way we contain them is things
like returning them to where they were
supposed to be on their historical path
or by trapping them in a pocket
dimension like a mirror dimension
enclosed in a sphere so that the means
by which those stones were knocked loose
from their universe could no longer
wreak havoc on the other timelines so
containment not destruction and really
that's been the mcu's general philosophy
with everything like with its villains
red skull zola zemo
loki the sinister six we're about to
find out dermamu hydra the cree the mcu
would rather shelve its threats
temporarily stowing them in exile for
future repurposing and so it's more
important for their rules to limit how
things can be killed than to limit how
many copies can respond they are always
forward thinking creation focused rather
than destruction and that's why it's
it's less common to hear the word kill
in mcu titles than destroy
i think it's just like a little thing
like they don't want things to ever have
a sense of permanent destruction yeah uh
just like kind of uh this wall like this
mole was whacked uh but
it's a mole
it's gonna come back yeah ever since
like superman came back to life in the
comics like i feel like comics and like
comic book companies are just like we
don't want to fully kill things now we
just want to sort of keep it on the
shelf for a little bit later so yeah it
does make sense for for you know marvel
studios to sort of do that with their or
want to do that rather with their
infinity stones and i think uh rule four
kind of is basically the groundwork for
all the rules right like that's why
marvel just kind of allows itself to
take these liberties uh and i think it's
what fans want ultimately you know we
want things to come back in new forms oh
yeah and then that's why there's a
multiverse right we just want to be like
okay well we kind of uh blew our gasket
on that universe let's let's see a new
universe where we can kind of start
fresh um but rule three in terms of like
any grievances people might have with
the infinity stones that's kind of the
one i'm clinging to right like uh this
idea of guest stones and native stones
like uh stones can coexist but the
stones that were uh native to that
universe are really the ones who are
kind of setting the house rules of that
yeah
but guest stones can kind of come in
there and uh and and you know like all
mothers-in-law kind of moves amongst
them
it's like i want this over here it's
like you're not supposed to do that but
i guess you technically can because
you're fine
okay i'm not gonna get in a fight with
you over right but fine just do it
because if i fight with you i'm not
getting any tonight so whatever you want
to do
but this will not be the last time we
talk about infinity stones in the mcu
trust me because people have a habit of
continuing to tweet us questions about
things we've made five videos about
already
whatever we're just happy to be tweeted
yeah
thank you so much it means that people
care about us well we have some more
questions we want to get to first we all
sometimes lose our sleep binging a show
or debating our loved ones over
something from the latest disney plush
show but you shouldn't lose any sleep
because of a bad mattress well helix
sleep has a quiz that matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you they have soft
medium and burn mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers i'm eric voss and i have a
helix mattress and i love it the quiz
match me with a medium firm matches
lumbar support that sleeps cool the
mattress ships right to your door for
free no need to go to a mattress store
just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty and you even get to try
it out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will love it helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com insidemarble
and guys there is nothing sexier than
confidence and bluetooth can give you
confidence where it counts bluechu is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
anytime day or night so you can plan
ahead and be ready for whenever an
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days and the
best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting line the
pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discrete package so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code inside marvel at checkout just pay
the five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month for free
visit bluetooth.com for more details
important safety information we thank
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
and adam and eve has been helping folks
have a good time in the bedroom for 50
years that's multiple generations of
freakiness
they got a huge selection of toys of the
adult variety massage oil even some
naughty board games that you can play
with your significant other they also
sell lingerie that you could definitely
fashion in some very scandalous cosplay
this halloween season adamandeve.com is
offering 50 off just about any item plus
free shipping on your entire order so
what do you have to do to get your 50
off one item and free shipping it's not
hard just go to adamandeve.com and
select any one item it could be an
adventurous new toy
anything you desire just enter the code
marvel at checkout and you'll get 50 off
any item go check out adamandeve.com
today select one item and get 50 off
including free shipping when you enter
offer code marvel that's m a r v e l
marvel at adamandeve.com all right empty
let's talk about uh the tva's connection
with everything we've seen in what if
what if the watcher is connected the tva
or connected to kang i think that's
highly likely considering you know the
tva does monitor different timelines and
the watcher does monitor different
timelines himself so it would be kind of
weird if you know the watcher in the tva
didn't at least interact like they did
in the comics because in the comics i
think there's like even instances where
the watcher is literally sitting in the
office of a tva agent just having a chat
because like they just know each other
so i think that the watcher does have
some type of tva connection and you know
probably it was probably even tight with
he who remains like they probably had a
good rapport and uh because he remains
was a very lonely man and so one of the
few people that he could probably even
talk to was uwatu the watcher i don't
know if talking to he who remains counts
as interference because he technically
is outside of everything so i don't know
but yeah i definitely think there is a
connection there agreed i think uh kang
and he remains have a um mutual shared
interest right with what the watchers
doing they they both as you said have
this sense of like isolation this
loneliness they observe the universe
they don't always interfere although
kang seems to like meddle in different
ways but he created his bureaucracy to
do it for him uh and so that he can just
kind of sit back and just kind of like
marvel over the script and do his math
equations and eat his apples but um but
yeah i think we're going to find out
that the watchers have like an
antagonistic relationship with the
celestials but like seems to have um a
cooperative relationship with the tva in
kang now does that mean that the watcher
is aware of how he's really doing kang's
bidding i feel like i feel like kang is
kind of like playing his script to fit
in with what the watcher is doing and
make the watcher feel like he's not
intervening but like it's kind of like
the people who um like the lobbyists who
benefit from any one presidential
administration's policies be like yeah
sure just keep doing what you're doing
baby we are gonna
reap the benefits of this uh yeah and i
think he's just kind of like he is
exploiting him in a way but not in a way
that the watcher feels like is bad i
think it's just kind of a script that uh
that kang has kind of set and the
watcher may not be totally aware that
he's uh playing into or maybe he knows
he's aware of kang but doesn't see him
as anything wrong he's kind of like well
this is just a script this guy is aware
of the script but i'm okay with it
because that's the script i'm not going
to question the script um i was really
hoping in the series we'd see a
conversation between
jonathan major
so good it's so satisfying i know maybe
season two or in quantum mania or
something like that maybe multiverse of
madness uh i that's that's the
conversation i i'm honestly more excited
for that than i would be to see mephisto
show up like seriously you owe us kevin
let's get it let's make it happen
fingers crossed yeah um all right mt i
want to ask you what if zombie thanos
ever breaches his universe i was kind of
expecting zombie thanos to plop in uh
yeah
when that portal opened up yeah cause
like where was he cause only wanda
popped through so like that makes me
wonder if wanda took care of him i don't
know but anyways um i think that it's
highly possible for a zombie thanos to
breach his universe because like we you
know alluded to earlier the problem with
thanos in our universe it compares in
comparison to ultron is that his body is
going is not as adorable as ultron but
if you're a zombie who gives a [ __ ] you
could like snap as much as you want
because you'll be totally fine so i
think that out of eddie thanos zombie
thanos is probably very likely to leave
his universe what do you think yeah uh
agreed i think this uh bodes well for
peter parker for t'challa for scotland
head scott lang with kate um because had
uh thanos acquired the mind stone there
all bets are off right but the fact that
like the worst thing to come out of that
universe would be wanda maximoff implies
that thanos never got that six stone and
they were able to keep it away from him
long enough but it makes me hope that in
season two we'll see like a follow-up to
that episode i'd love to see a sequel
that follows those three trying to
survive wakanda trying to keep away from
like a deadly zombie thanos who can use
a time stone if we can use a reality
stone like i'm super excited to see what
that would look like and then maybe at
some point like all the there's like a
drain that opens up and all the horde of
zombies falls out and then just kind of
dovetails in with with a season one
finale yo i really hope that this that
that world somehow crosses into far from
i mean no way home because like even
though it's highly unlikely oh and like
because there's two separate productions
i think it'd be really cool if peter
parker just briefly was like hey what's
going on it's like oh there's me in a
very more depressed me i guess um
another question i want to ask you what
if the sakara gamora episode could have
actually been delayed for plot reasons
and i brought this up i i think people
thought i was going too hard on
animators for like uh for lying to us i
know the code restrictions make it
really hard to produce anything so i i
think that they were partly telling the
truth that there were covered reasons
why it had been delayed i just think
that wasn't the only reason just because
you know my fiance also works for pixar
and they animated an entire film luca
from home uh i know it can be done and
uh don't tell me that the animation on
luca was harder to make than a given
episode of what if that had beautiful
animation that
is life-changing when you watch it uh so
if they can do that the the team at
marvel can animate an episode of what if
from home they could figure it out um
especially with the amount of time they
had to produce this series um but uh is
like we saw those wolverine claws do we
think that there was like wolverine in
this episode and then they're like wait
do we have a plan to introduce wolverine
and if you just push us to season two
trust us
like am i crazy i think that it would be
really fun if they did delay it because
like hey you know what if we're gonna
put claws in the mcu it's gotta be
wolverine first that would be hilarious
um but i definitely i think that there
probably is some type of plot reason for
you know them delaying it to the next
episode because maybe this car episode
teases you know another big threat and
like they just didn't want to like iron
man to it a little bit because like all
right like let's just keep it to this
ultron thing and like you know if i i
have a feeling that they probably went
into the whole tentacle subplot that was
introduced in episode one so they're
probably just like you know what
we're not gonna get into it this season
apparently because this is just the
ultron season but like
we'll we'll just save that for a a
season two episode yeah a lot of people
have asked us if this is that um
guardians volume three story line that
we heard about the beginning of the
season that there was one pitch story
line that marvel said was too similar to
guardians volume 3 and james gunn is
like i have no idea what you're talking
about but uh i don't think this is it
because that was referring to an episode
that was pitched never storyboarded or
animated or anything clearly this was a
different idea that was mapped out they
scripted it out they started to shoot it
and then they had to just delay it so
that's a different thing i don't think
that guardians volume three esque story
ever made it to storyboard uh or i
wonder if it had to do with jeff
goldblum and his availability almost
because like we know he was doing stuff
for for disney plus and all that stuff
but maybe like covet or something like
they wanted to get jeff goldblum because
who's gonna really do a jeff goldblum
impression like let's be real because if
this doesn't take place once a couple
years you can't you can't do it you
can't so
i don't know
maybe maybe i just it seems like so they
were able to get dialogue from uh
goldblum for other episodes from kurt
russell where all these big name actors
were able to go into their closets and
then record a thing because that's what
you have to do you make the actor go in
their closet and then uh and because
that's what has the best oh the price of
acting
yeah
all right mt let's end on the question
of how does this series rank for you
compared to one division falcon winner
soldier and loki
this is it's always difficult to write
something especially
i hate it okay you know what for me i'm
gonna say
i'm gonna say one division i'm gonna say
loki
then what if then falcon the winner
soldier and no disrespect the falcon
weird soldier because those are these we
were all so blessed to have
amazing shows this year like yes the
fact that we had all these programs is
mind-blowing but i do like what if a
little bit more than falcon lunar
soldier because i just personally like
cosmic [ __ ] like wanda vision loki
my that's my thing i love it what do you
think how about you agreed um similar
rankings i actually love one division a
lot more than the falcon winter soldier
i think the falcon winter soldier has
some good elements to it but like just
too many of the subplots just were
really underdeveloped i loved the sam
wilson isaiah bradley stuff uh i thought
all the uh john walker storyline
especially in the final episode they
really just kind of wasted the character
uh and like just kind of made him this
weirdly vaguely redemptive character it
was so weird abraham lincoln
um anyway i might have gone into my
thoughts on [ __ ] winter soldier my
ranking would be uh just slightly
altered from yours i think fourth would
be falcon winner soldier third would be
what it but there's a big gap between
those and then my top two i really go
back and forth i i think uh i love i
think i would go number two one division
number one loki but i go back and forth
on those to be honest with you because i
think nothing uh across any of these
shows
moved me more than uh wanda's
relationship with vision throughout
wanda vision i thought it was so
beautifully written and it made me love
the character of vision you know i
before one division i wasn't crazy about
the character of vision
i thought he was really an underwritten
weird character
but
they rescued this character from me and
made me feel all kinds of feels uh and
the fact they introduced uh agatha
harkness you know they did so much cool
world building the concept of the
sitcoms i just think the subplot you
know i haven't really thought too much
about monica rambo since that season
came out i think she was a cool
character i just think like her
backstory with uh with carol danvers
just seemed to be just kind of hinted at
and they never really did a lot of
character building with her
so when looking back when she powers up
into spectrum like i i or photon you
know i i didn't really feel a whole lot
from that um but i still love so much of
the show but the reason i kind of rank
loki number one is like everything about
that show
really stuck the landing i think by the
end like it was so ambitious with the
fact that they were able to like rewrite
the rules every episode and still kind
of like maintain continuity and do such
great character development with uh with
loki laughs and and with sylvie uh and
with owen wilson as mobius and with rent
slayer like every part of that show felt
like they got an interesting arc by the
end and the fact that they could end
that series with he remains just
monologuing at us dancing around that
room and i'm enthralled i am gripped i'm
staring at it i'm like holy crap but
ask me ask me next week mt i'll make a
case for white wanavision was the number
one show i i hate ranking
um
but that's kind of where i'm at oh no
100 loki was a phenomenal program like
the set design of loki literally yeah
production design incredible yeah ten
out of ten but i but ultimately i you
know i can find things to love about all
four of these shows i'm with umt i feel
blessed that we got all four of these
that we can now exist in a world where
every week we get a new piece of mcu
lore that we can break down and discuss
and react to like right man we are in a
golden age like i thought after end game
i didn't know where the mc was going to
go next but the fact that like
i mean it's kind of crazy like the rules
do change and sometimes ways that break
all the rules that came before but i'm
loving this right now oh absolutely like
it ain't 2008 no more like we have grown
since then yeah
um so uh that's it for this episode of
uh inside marvel but empty and i are
gonna be back every wednesday to answer
your biggest marvel questions whether
it's about eternal spiderman no way home
hawkeye and beyond so stay tuned every
wednesday we're going to be here
answering it all uh don't forget to
check out our many great merch options
at new yorkstarsmerch.com follow me at
ea boss follow mt mastertainment follow
and subscribe to new rockstars and of
course subscribe to inside marvel
wherever your podcast thanks for
watching and we will see you next week
everyone bye
[Music]
you